Okay, so will you work this out? You will need
to know the frequency of A, B, C, and D. But
we already know that. You will also need to know
how many bits each of those symbols require. Now we also
know that. So, we will calculate the expected number of
bits to transmit each symbol and then add them up. So
for any symbol, the expected number of bits is given
by the probability of seeing that symbol, and the size required
to transmit that symbol. And we add them up for all the symbols in the language.
This is going to give us 1.75 bits on an average. Now, since we had to ask
less questions in this language, than the previous
language, this language has less information. This is
also called as variable length encoding. This should
give you some idea into figuring out why some
symbols in Morse code are smaller than others. In
the English alphabet, the letters e and t occur
most frequently. That's why, in the Morse code, e
is generated by a dot and t is generated by
a dash. Since e and t occur more frequently,
they have the smallest message size. This measure, which calculates
the number of bits per symbol, is also called
as entropy. And it is mathematically given as this formula.
To make it more legible, we need to find out how
to denote the size of s more properly. The size of s
is also given by the log of 1 upon the probability
of that symbol. So the formula of entropy is given as this.